[MUSIC PLAYING]
GWEN MCNAMARA:
One day when I was
trying to think about
finding time in my day
to disconnect a little
bit and take a break,
I decided, you
know what, I'm just
gonna put on my sneakers or
whatever and I'm just gonna walk.
I'm just gonna walk in a
particular direction.
And so just happened to come
past the -- by the neuroscience
building and I saw
this little trail --
this little rock and
a little inviting
path that wended into
the woods a little bit.
And I thought, huh, I
wonder where that goes?
And it was beautiful.
It was just so
lovely to escape just
for a little bit, the
asphalt, and the buildings
and feel like you were
diving back into the woods.
It's nice to be able to
walk in and you immediately
begin to see the dappled
sunshine as it filters
through the leaves and
plays with light and shadows
on the ground.
I tend to be looking
down as I'm going
and can see who's
been there too.
So when you see
some animal prints --
sometimes you can hear
a bird off to the side
and if you're lucky be able to
spot it before it disappears.
But just noticing everything
from the small details
of the wildflowers, or the
leaves, to the larger trees,
it's just really calming and
beautiful to walk down and lose
yourself in these surroundings.
My grandfather, on my
dad's side, had a farm.
And so growing up we spent
a ton of our time as kids
just exploring and having fun.
And so, for me, when I think
about places and periods
of time that bring
me joy, it's always
seems to be tied to nature.
And it makes me
feel better knowing
that maybe something
I'm worrying about, maybe
it's not such a big deal in
the grand scheme of things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]